let's face it the holidays can be tough
for
us lgbtq plus people especially in a
time where we can't be
physically near the people who love and
support us and make us feel good
during this time of social distancing
many lgbtq plus people have to spend
their holidays alone
without their families whether it be
chosen or biological
glaad and outfest are locking arms to
make sure that
every lgbtq person sees their
own stories reflected our community is
resilient
lgbtq people are powerful
and we're stronger together even if we
can't be together
in person we can be together
in pride queer people need to take care
of ourselves right now
i'm talking self-care i know you've seen
it on social media
so let's do it be kind to yourself this
season
i feel like everyone has a chosen family
the friends that they choose to surround
themselves with and it can be very small
or it can be very big
i love my friends i don't know um they
are
you know a support system i'm able to
talk to them
you know when about things that
i might not feel totally comfortable
talking to my parents about i think
that's
that's sort of why we surround ourselves
with with friends it's
is for the good times and the bad times
the people that i hold on to
um i feel like i would do anything for
them it's um
i don't think family necessarily means
unconditional but it does mean that you
are safe to like
change and like explore and mess up and
learn
i do have a chosen family of wonderful
girlfriends and they are important to me
because they love me
and support me no matter what they are
just the kind of friends that you walk
through life
with that mean everything to you one day
hopefully soon we'll be able to join
together
celebrate one another but for now we
have to stay safe wear a mask
and stay healthy we stand with you all
year long
we are truly together in pride let's
start the new year with renewed hope
from our chosen family to yours we wish
you all
love joy and pride happy
holidays happy holidays
happy holidays
[Music]
like